what is up everyone we're in a suburb of
Boston's npcville asking strangers what
they think about Andrew Tate let's get
into it what are your thoughts on Andrew
Tate um
why because his his opinions don't like
I don't like I just I don't agree with
it what opinion
um cheating and everything like that
stuff also my boyfriend believes in it
so I don't I don't like it your
boyfriend rocks your tape but you don't
yeah he follows him on Instagram so I
don't know about that one yeah
so because of the cheating stuff is that
the big thing or anything else I don't I
don't know anything else about him so
well hopefully your boyfriend doesn't
cheat on you at least she listed a
reason you know a lot of the other ones
have zero clue but he does say men can
cheat in women can't so I guess you
gotta give it to her there I'm sure you
guys have heard of him but what are your
thoughts on Andrew tape he's not a good
person why he just got arrested for what
so like sex trafficking a real reason a
real reason
that's the Matrix you've heard it you've
watched The Matrix right no no I'm out
all right do you do you disagree with
like anything he said you think I know
everything
I'm asking you I'm sure you guys have
heard of them but what are your thoughts
on Andrew Tate I [ __ ] hate that guy
why because he's a misogynistic piece of
[ __ ] what do you think I just don't like
him he's just a bad person I can't name
anything specific but I just don't like
him like I just don't like his Vibe and
like his
General personality do you think that's
a problem that like the people that
bullied me in high school so I just
don't like him I love Andrew That's my
boy oh no dude you just pissed your girl
off
what do you think of them yeah no
because here's a hit let me let me tell
you something people hate Andrew Tate
but they never give a real reason on why
oh yeah I always hear feminist what has
he actually said that says F women
quite the opposite exactly what I'm
saying man he's just mad because he my
man
oh don't what it's not it's a non-carbon
emitting camera
even if it's non-carbon emitting
but what saves them it helps the
environment no but you're freaking rough
all right well I guess we'll just go
save the environment elsewhere put it
away
all right thank you boss oh you're good
bro thanks for your guys
like he's like radioing and [ __ ] what
are your thoughts on Andrew Tate I hope
but that's not true though what what do
you mean it's not that's just the news
titles it's the Matrix attacking them
there's facts behind it
no there's no facts behind it I'm sorry
have you like disagreed with anything
that he said like everything
yeah like what specifically here I
actually got you a little gift I'll give
you five dollars if you can tell me like
something specific that he said with
context that you don't like well he
believes men are better than women which
isn't true that everyone's equal despite
their gender no no he thinks that men
and women have their differences so like
a woman would be better with like
nurturing kids you know making like a
nice home stuff like that and Men you
know go out and do the BS they go to war
they get bullets flown at them not
necessarily true women go to war too and
there's also plenty of stay-at-home dads
who do just as fine with the job okay
all right well thank you for your time I
hope you have a great day
I think that's the wrong way
oh [ __ ]
this is the only way to go down it's an
elevator right there be careful man yeah
be careful what are your thoughts on
Andrew Tate he kind of sucks I don't
know why does he suck I heard he's
racists or something kind of yeah this I
don't know it's just everything I heard
he sounds like terrible what are your
thoughts on him he definitely is not a
good person and I think that he's
manipulating little boys to be [ __ ]
like my brother is in love with that guy
and it's creepy I don't like it your
brother becoming an [ __ ] yes he's
been an [ __ ] and it just got worse oh
no all right here I have a little prize
though I have five dollars if you can
give me one specific reason like
something that Tate has said of why you
don't like him oh well he got arrested
that's something that happened to him
but that's just like a swatting like any
I could call you know someone to your
house and say What's it whatever your
name is you know she has 10 kids
kidnapped in the basement and the cops
would show up as they should you know
what I mean so is there like one thing
that he said that's maybe influenced
your brother watch him but my brother
thinks that every one of his tick tocks
is good so I don't know don't you think
that's kind of a problem to have a
strong opinion and get emotional about
someone that you don't even know like
why I don't have a strong opinion I just
think that my brother is acting like a
[ __ ] and he says it's Andrew Tate like
mentality I think that's just him being
stupid but he says things like oh that's
he'll like do an [ __ ] thing you know
just be like that's the Tate mentality
I'm probably just messing with you then
I don't know
well thank you guys for your time
it's not necessarily a protein video but
a lot of people have specific views on
them they don't like them and nobody
seems to know why so I'm trying to dig
down beneath it and see why people don't
like tape I actually did see one
interview with him where he was saying
that like if he had a girlfriend she
wouldn't be allowed to go on
yeah that was probably taking a little
bit out of context but for the most part
he thinks that you know he doesn't want
his women like going out to clubs alone
and putting themselves in scenarios
where there's a bunch of guys coming up
to them that's kind of his take but the
whole time while he was interviewing
with the lady he was interrupting the
woman like crazy like he wouldn't even
let her speak yeah I don't know which
one you're talking about specifically
but all right thank you guys so much for
your time as garminia you almost feel
bad for the people with the slave Minds
like you just want to free them like you
know she gets right off the bat she's
like oh no is this a protake video no I
don't like tape and then you ask her and
you're like you know like what is he
said and she's like well my brother
watches him I don't know and then you
know you how you tell her you're like
that's a problem you don't even know
what he said and you have a strong
response and she's like oh I don't know
they're just spots like you almost feel
bad for him you know what I mean free
the slave mind top G
um I don't like Andrew Tate why not I
really don't like him but I do like his
streams with Aiden Ross but I don't like
I don't believe his morals or values
what are some of his morals and values
that you don't agree with speak your
truth I don't know you go I actually am
not educated on this subject so I'm
gonna say no comment okay that's very
valid why don't you like them anything I
just think he's
smart I got a prize for you well almost
but I'll give you five dollars if you
can name one thing that he said that's
actually misogynistic and not just like
a news title
that's a coffee
Starbucks dunkaccino double frappe I
don't know I don't drink that [ __ ]
wait let me take a seat
you can take a second I'm not in a rush
can we use our phones
I think it's misogynistic when he
explains that
yep
he women are his property
okay like like well like there's like
more to it than like women are just I'm
not an encyclopedia on Andrew no that's
fine so like the thing with Tate is like
a lot of people just take his Clips out
of context and I'd watch like a full-on
podcast of him and everything and you
still didn't rock with him after a
full-on podcast
for the girls if I'm gonna be honest no
he's for the boys protecting and
providing for the girls but not for like
who so who would you rather be dependent
on like a corporation or a husband that
that truly loves you I feel like my
husband wouldn't truly love me if he's
entertained he's [ __ ] all these other
women
as a girl I when I love someone I don't
want to sleep with anyone else so that's
my that's good that's her take so that's
why I just don't like rock with him yeah
you don't know your guy going out and
sleeping with it I mean I understand it
like I'm a reasonable guy here you know
I'm just I also recognize that it's like
it's different for men and women you
know what I mean I don't think I just
see I think that's like a double
standard I don't think it's different
for men and women all right well that's
your opinion real quick I know a lot of
you guys have been clipping up these
videos and posting them on Tick Tock so
I did the liberty of cutting up a bunch
of clips for you guys and throwing them
in a Google drive you to download and
post yourself so the link will be at the
top of the description of this YouTube
video you can download the individual
Clips add in your own subtitles music
micro Cuts all that kind of stuff and
throw it on Tick Tock yourself to go
viral see you off back to the video he
can rot in jail why don't you like him
because he's mean to women like he beats
women but that was consent like you talk
about that video
what is it okay if that was consensual
no never hit a woman like even in bed
when they're playing around that's not
okay I wasn't playing
or later well she said afterwards that
it was consensual does that change
things or no all right you got me there
I'm not trying to just like get you like
like why though I don't know I just
don't like his attitude what about you
anything he said specifically no he's
just like when he went on like the the
podcast or whatever with like Josh
Richards he was just kind of like
narcissistic and rude you just don't
like his attitude no but nothing really
like specific like any specific morals
that he has or points that he makes that
you disagree with no I just don't like
him all right well thank you guys for
your time
yeah let's make sure to totally keep
that in Alex what are your thoughts on
Andrew Tate these balls bald sad
I used to be bald when I was little I
mean make sense
I had cancer oh wow so sorry about that
I know it's all good but what are your
thoughts on entertain I mean it's also
that and then looks like what he looks
like so I mean literally it's a loose
loose you don't like his looks no what
has he said that you don't like
what owned by a 19 year old like that's
kind of sad he's like 50 or something
what do you say got owned by like a 19
year old yeah owned by a 19 year old
yeah what
oh because Greta Thurman uh ratio yeah
and then he like [ __ ] leaked his
location and got arrested it's like damn
yeah well free take guys all right thank
you guys so much for your time have a
good one dude they're just Bots bro
s bro it's like the most NPC responses
we're not filming don't worry we're just
it's taking 30 pictures a second
[Music]
we'll just step out man no worries all
right thank you
the mall cops are [ __ ] closing in
right now we're taking off don't worry
okay
all right thank you that's why we're
heading out we got kicked out of the
last mall so we're now at the Prudential
Center a whole lot of yuppies what are
your thoughts on Andrew Tate I don't
think she's good I think this person no
why not why don't you rock with them I
said some bad things what has he said
I don't really know I just heard people
say that he's bad so I think he's bad
don't you think that's a problem that
you just like hear other people say that
and then you you like adopt that
thinking or um no no you don't think so
no
all right guys have a good one
pots bro they're bad
what are your thoughts on Andrew tape I
don't like him why do you like him
I'm an [ __ ] is you know what you
don't know who entertain is scary man
yeah the Romanian dude yeah
guys so why don't you guys like him like
what has he said that you disagree with
uh well then I I don't really watch any
of his [ __ ] because I don't like care
you know I I don't no I get that I don't
keep up with that kind of stuff but I
just the only video I've ever seen of
him was him like saying like women can't
drive and [ __ ] like that just like every
stereotype but I mean I don't really
okay I don't care what he says do you
have any thoughts or anything he hates
women no he doesn't he doesn't hate
women he just sounds like
it I like I like a lot of his message uh
having a strong mind strong bodies a
strong mind a lot of his business advice
is really good a lot of stuff he says
about women isn't necessarily just like
men are better than women and what a lot
of people think he says like you should
protect and provide for your girl and
stuff like that and like as a man you
should take on the hardship in a
relationship and your woman what if
there's not a man in the relationship
yeah oh if it's two girls or something
yeah I mean I mean that's different
that's totally fine too I mean I guess
that's like fine but I feel like it
shouldn't always be that way yeah like
why do you have to have gender roles why
can't you just well naturally you revert
to gender roles when [ __ ] hits the fan
you know so like if let's say we went to
war the men would be going on the man
do you not believe in gender roles at
all
I mean like they're obviously
you recognize that like obviously like
men are just like physically stronger
than women so you're realistic like
biological standpoint yeah but like
socially no maybe even like work and
[ __ ] like yeah but that's not like
controlled by that's controlled by more
like social [ __ ] but I think like just
general standpoint no men aren't more
like protective or more they shouldn't
be more predicted they shouldn't have
more like Oh I'm a man I need to protect
my woman if she doesn't want so like if
you have a boyfriend and let's say
someone breaks into the house you
wouldn't expect for your guy to be the
one to run down and deal with that [ __ ]
you run you'd run down 100 oh I would
run down that I'd be like get the [ __ ]
out of my house [ __ ] even in like a gay
relationship is there one person that
would take that role of like I'm the one
that's gonna deal with [ __ ] if someone
I'm just asking a question too like yeah
but I feel like if you're in like a
straight relationship it doesn't
necessarily mean that that's the man so
just because you're the man you're
saying you don't have to do that
I totally agree that the girl has to do
[ __ ] sometimes too but I wouldn't want
my girl to have to do like the physical
stuff to protect you no I I if if [ __ ]
goes down no like that's not I just no I
just don't believe that's her job like
if if a guy is truly being violent and
wants to hurt someone I don't think my
girl should be standing in between that
I think she should be running and try to
find safety and the dudes should try to
fight she should if she doesn't she can
run if she wants she wants to but if
it's an angry guy she's gonna get
whacked I think it's very fair I don't
want to protect your girlfriend or
whatever but I think but it's also very
fair for the girlfriend to want to
protect the boyfriend please I agree
with you like the girl wants to but like
if I had a girlfriend which I don't I
would say like like get out of here like
if someone's like trying to hurt us you
know what I mean
yeah no it's I definitely understand the
like okay I want to protect her yeah but
I don't think that it necessarily is
because she's a woman or because you're
a man what if a man doesn't want to do
it every time what if what if the man
gets tired that's tough [ __ ] though
another thing he says is like you don't
do what you want to do you do what
you're supposed to do use your cerebral
cortex what should I be doing now
type [ __ ] not even just natural instinct
just like do I feel like going to the
gym no should I go yes and
in your best interest in the long term
and the short term okay like
Pate might be seeing this so do you have
any message for him go Michigan State
Spartans
okay
respectful bugs yeah upstairs
no I post this on YouTube but here I'll
show you okay you wanna throw it down
thank you guys for being like respectful
though you know a lot of people just get
like angry
at the end of the day it's like you
still want to protect people so like
whatever that's your thing do that
perfect and you'll find a girlfriend
you'll find a [ __ ] girlfriend
[Applause]
thank you guys so much for watching as
expected all that NPC answers but we
were able to free some Minds you know
some people finally cook for them that
maybe it doesn't make sense to have a
strong emotional opinion about someone
that you don't even know why but yeah
thanks for watching make sure to like
subscribe drop a follow I'm giving a
hundred dollars to someone who follows
my Instagram and comments on my last
post that Winners going up soon so make
sure you enter that and yeah thank you
all peace
[Music]
won't last long yeah the feelings
[Music]